[Musique]
encore aujourd'hui près de 600 000
personnes regardent chaque semaine en
reprise les vieux épisodes de la petite
vie
30 ans après sa création Claude Munier a
décidé de faire revivre ses personnages
cultes l'essentiel des rapports
familiaux a tout changé tant que je sais
pas c'est une petite vie qui se passe
maintenant mais c'est toujours le même
univers la même bulle des paris des
retrouvailles qui ont des airs de fêtes
de famille la famille Paris c'était
quelque chose exceptionnel dans tous nos
parcours à chacun de nous donc c'était
en arrière ce c'était un beau souvenir
de se faire dire hey on revient on
revient pour 6 émissions avec tout le
monde a dit oui spontanément des
épisodes de 30 minutes qui seront
enregistrés devant public dans les mêmes
décors et la même ambiance qu'à l'époque
ce espèce de folie qui a en arrière de
tout ça qui fait du bien
tellement que les personnages toute la
famille on est on est vraiment au top de
notre personnage on parle lol mais dans
la petite vie comme dans la vie 30 ans
sont écoulés il y aura pas de clash
parce que les gens vont voir qu'on a
évolué ou non de Panama des personnes
le moteur de cette nouvelle mouture de
la petite vie le plaisir on se fait rire
si on a toujours une espèce de petit
fébrilité quand on joue ensemble on est
toujours au bord de rire de d'avoir des
fous rires ça c'est toujours très bon
signe pour c'est toujours garant de
plaisir
elle avait besoin d'un breize qui s'est
retiré de la vie publique ne participera
pas au projet et ne sera pas remplacé
mais à défaut d'être à l'écran moment
sera présente dans tous les esprits je
savais que Serge sera pas là parce que
je parle à Serge à l'époque je savais
qu'il comme à la retraite puis que
décide de sortir et compte tenu de ce
que tout le monde sait puis je veux pas
rentrer là-dedans mais
j'ai appelé tout le monde si avec
quelqu'un qui avait pas été là je
l'aurais pas fait aucune date précise
n'a été annoncée mais les six nouveaux
épisodes seront disponibles sur ici tout
est vie extra au cours de la saison 2023
2024 et seront ensuite diffusés sur Easy
TV
ici Nabil Alexandre Chartier
Radio-Canada Montréal